GUY KAWASAKI: Good afternoon.
My name is Guy
Kawasaki, and I am
a resident of Silicon Valley.
I have a long history.
I'm pretty old.
Many of you may know of
me from this context.
So I was Apple's second
software evangelist.
So I am here today
to talk to you
about the art of evangelism.
It's something that I learned
in the Macintosh division,
as well as an entrepreneur, and
as a chief evangelist of Canva.
So these are the
skills that I would
like to pass on to
you so that you can,
in the words of Steve
Jobs, "dent the universe,"
make the world a better place.
For those of you who have seen
a lot of high tech speakers,
I think you'll relate to this.
There are two
fundamental qualities
of most high tech speakers.
First, almost all of them suck.
And second, almost
all of them go long.
And that is a
deadly combination.
If you suck, and
you go long, wow.
you're short, OK.
If you're great,
and you're long, OK.
But sucking and going
long, bad combination.
Double whammy.
And so what I do is I use a
top 10 format for my speeches.
So I have 10 key points for you.
So in case you think I
suck, you know approximately
how much longer I'll suck
because I have exactly 10
points for you, OK?
So point number one,
and I think this
is the key to marketing and
engineering, and therefore,
evangelism.
By the way, "evangelism"
comes from Greek terminology,
or Greek words, meaning
"bringing the good news."
So as a Macintosh evangelist,
as a Canva evangelist,
I was bringing the
good news of Macintosh,
or Macintosh would make people
more creative and productive,
Canva enables you to
create great graphics.
And so by bringing
the good news,
I learned that this is the most
important concept in marketing.
If you can get this
concept, game over.
It's all you need.
So it is a 2 by 2 matrix.
The horizontal axis is
the value of your product.
The vertical axis is
the uniqueness or degree
of differentiation
of your product.
So we'll go through
all four corners.
On the bottom right-hand
corner, that's
where you have something that's
valuable, but it is not unique.
So it's useful, it's
just not unique.
It is Michael Dell slapping
the same version of Windows
on the same hardware.
You can make a lot
of money there,
but it's always about price.
In the opposite corner, you have
something that's truly unique,
but it is not valuable.
It is useless.
In that corner, you
are just plain stupid.
In the bottom left-hand
corner, you are stupid,
and it's crowded with
other stupid people.
That bottom left corner, I
like to cite the dot-com days.
In particular, pets.com.
So pets.com, let's
reminisce about pets.com.
In pets.com, you would
buy dog food online.
And the proposition
of pets.com was
that now we can
sell you direct, we
can eliminate the
retail distribution
channel, discount dog food.
So yes, you discount
dog food, but then you
have to add back
shipping and handling.
So the reason why pets.com
wasn't that valuable
was because, yes, you
discounted it at the top line,
but then you had to add
back shipping and handling,
because you had to get
the dead cow in the can
to the dog owner.
And also, somebody had to be
at home when UPS dropped off
the dead cow in the can.
If you weren't there,
it left you a little tag
that said, "We attempted to drop
off the dead cow in the can.
No one was home.
We're going to attempt to drop
off the dead cow in the can
tomorrow.
If no one's home
again, we're going
to send the dead cow in the
can back to the factory."
So it was inconvenient
and just as expensive.
Why was pets.com in
such a crowded market?
It's because people
in Silicon Valley,
like me, fell for this pitch.
Never use a pitch
along these lines, OK?
There are 300 million Americans.
1 in 4 owns a dog.
75 million dogs.
Each dog eats two cans
of dog food per day.
Total addressable market of
150 million cans of dog food
per day.
And dog food is
not a B2B business.
It's not a five day
a week business,
Monday through Friday.
Dogs eat every day.
We're talking B2C, or
more accurately, B2D.
Dogs eat everyday.
So you take 150 million
cans of dog food per day,
how hard could it be to
get 1% of that with my rock
star, programmer co-founder?
1% of 150 million cans
of dog food per day
is 1 and 1/2 million cans of
dog food per day, times 365.
We're talking 500 or 600
million cans of dog food a year.
That's why there was pets.com,
mypets.com, epets.com,
peapodpets.com, webandpets.com.
There were 16 ways to
buy dog food online.
But the corner you
truly want to be in
is in the upper
right-hand corner.
So whether you wear an
engineering hat or a marketing
hat, that's where the action is.
With Canva, we're
trying to create
something that's powerful,
easy to use, and cheap--
the holy grail of
creating graphics.
Macintosh was in that
upper right-hand corner.
It was the first computer
that mere mortals could use.
When iPod first came
out, it was the only way
you could get a lot of music
legally and inexpensively.
Breitling makes a watch
called a Breitling Emergency.
And if you unscrew the big
knob at the 5 o'clock position,
it starts broadcasting
an emergency signal.
That emergency signal
is caught by planes.
If you pull that thing out,
and you set this alarm off,
next thing you
know, Kevin Costner
is in the Coast Guard
helicopter in the basket,
coming to rescue you.
That's a watch that
can save your life.
There are not many watches
that can save your life.
Mercedes makes a smart car.
All of us have cars that can
park parallel to the curb.
How many of us have cars
that can park perpendicular
to the curb?
So I think this explains most of
evangelism and marketing, which
is make a product that
is unique and valuable.
If it's unique,
but not valuable,
it'll always, always be stupid.
If you are valuable,
but not unique,
you always have to
compete on price.
If you're not unique and not
valuable, you're just pathetic.
You don't even
register on the radar.
This is the holy
grail of evangelism--
getting in the upper right-hand
corner of this graph.
Number two.
Number two is my insight,
and it took me a long time
to figure this out--
you have to remove
all the speed bumps.
I think that one
of the things that
gets in the way of
new product adoption
is that you get too
close to the product,
and you think, oh, people won't
mind doing this kind of thing.
They won't mind giving you their
credit card, even though you're
giving them a free account.
They won't mind having to do
all kinds of rekeying of data
because our database
is so great.
And these kinds of
speed bumps count.
They are a terrible friction
upon new product adoption
and evangelism.
A very good test for
this, by the way,
is not that you are willing
to go through with this.
It's to give it to your
spouse or your parents,
and say, sign up
for our service.
See if you can do it.
Remove the speed bumps.
Number three.
Number three is my
observation that if you
want to create a
great company today,
you have to attack the
incumbents from below.
For example, with Canva,
fundamentally, we're
competing with Adobe, right?
So Adobe has Photoshop
and Illustrator.
And so there are two strategies.
One strategy would
be, well, you could
make something that's more
powerful than Photoshop,
more powerful than Illustrator.
That would be the go above them.
I think the way to
attack an incumbent
is always to go
from beneath them--
so less powerful, simpler,
cheaper, easier to use.
If you attack from below,
you can always move up.
But if you attack from
above, you cannot move down.
With Macintosh, we tried to
attack the IBM PC from below.
We weren't trying to
make a computer more
powerful than the IBM PC.
We were trying to make a
computer more easy, more
inexpensive, more fun to use.
So my advice as you try
to attack the incumbents
is attack from below,
not from above.
Number four.
Number four is my
observation in evangelism
that you have to learn to ignore
people's titles and pedigrees.
That just because they're
the CIO, CMO, CTO,
CXO, just because they went to,
well, Yale in particular right
now, it doesn't mean that
they're competent or smart.
And my observation
is that the higher
you go in most organizations,
the thinner the air.
And the thinner the
air, the more difficult
it is to support
intelligent life.
And so if you try to enter
an organization from the top,
inevitably, you will be
dealing with the dumbest
people in the organization.
Ignore people's
titles and pedigrees.
When you are trying to
evangelize something,
you don't care about their
titles and pedigrees.
All you care about
is that they get it.
There was no CIO or CTO
in a Fortune 500 company
that grokked Macintosh.
It was always the graphic
designer, the artist,
the photographer, the slide
maker, the presentation,
the newsletter maker.
It was all the people at
the middles and the bottoms.
Get in through the bottom.
Get in through the middle.
Ignore people's
titles and pedigrees.
Number five.
Number five is you have
to learn to suck up.
It is a fact of life
that you have to suck up.
Just deal with that.
Don't be proud.
You have to suck up to be in
the featured at the Play Store.
You have to suck up to be
featured at the Apple Store.
You have to be sucking
up to get in the Start
on Android program.
It's a cost of doing business.
Get over it.
It's worth it.
At one point, I was running
the Apple Developer channel,
so I was on the opposite
side of this discussion.
And we would run
co-marketing with developers.
And you know what?
We worked with the
people that we liked.
They had to have good
products, don't get me wrong.
But it was people who wanted
our help, who were nice to us.
It wasn't just because
they had a great product.
And I learned a very
humbling and important lesson
that, sometimes, in life,
you just have to suck up.
Because, man, being on the
front page of an app store
can make your product succeed.
So get over it.
Learn to suck up.
Number six.
Number six is to learn
to niche thyself.
I think many people,
when they look
at a company, a
successful company,
they forget the first
20 years of the company.
So you look at something
like Microsoft or Apple,
and you say, wow, look at Apple.
They have hardware.
They have software.
They have applications.
They have content.
Look at Microsoft.
They have hardware,
software, gaming.
They have cloud.
They have everything.
And so we need a grand plan.
Look at Google.
They have Search.
They have Analytics.
They have cars.
They have blocks of salt
that's going to store energy.
They have ways to count
fish in fish farms.
They have everything.
And so there's
this grand scheme.
So you're two guys in a garage,
two gals in a garage, a guy
and a gal in a
garage, and you think,
we're going to be like Google,
and Microsoft, and Apple.
So someday, we need
an operating system.
We need an app.
We need hardware.
We need software.
We need cloud.
We need e-commerce.
We need the whole thing.
That's not how it works.
I think the way it works is
you own one niche at a time.
You get one niche, and
then you get another niche,
and then you get another niche.
And one day, you wake
up, and my god, you
have achieved
worldwide domination.
It is not because you planned
for worldwide domination.
It is because, to use
a bowling pin analogy,
you knocked over one pin, and
then another pin, and then
another pin.
And then you turned around,
and one day, you had a strike.
But it wasn't because you had
all those pins knocked down
on one ball.
You took them down
one at a time.
A very good academic
orientation for this,
or explanation of this,
is "Crossing the Chasm"
by Geoffrey Moore.
I highly recommend that book--
"Crossing the Chasm"
by Geoffrey Moore.
The point here is niche thyself.
Go after one niche, then
another, and another,
and another.
And wake up and declare victory
with worldwide domination.
Number seven.
Number seven is stolen
from Chairman Mao,
though I fail to see how he
ever implemented this, which is,
"Let 100 flowers blossom."
And by this, I mean
when you have innovated,
when you have
shipped your product,
you take your best shot at
positioning and branding.
With Macintosh, we thought we
had a spreadsheet, database,
and word processing machine.
Basically, we were 0
for 3 in the mid-'80s.
People weren't embracing
Macintosh for spreadsheet,
database, or word processing.
They embraced Macintosh
for desktop publishing.
Desktop publishing was a
gift from God to Apple.
It saved Apple.
Without desktop publishing,
there would be no Apple today.
I believe in God, and one of
the reasons why I believe in God
is there is no other explanation
for Apple's continued
survival than a benevolent God.
So God gave Apple PageMaker.
And PageMaker created
a field of flowers
called desktop publishing.
But you know what?
We were focusing on spreadsheet,
database, and word processor,
not desktop publishing.
A more analog example.
Suppose you work for
Avon, the CMO of Avon.
And you have this product.
It's called Skin So Soft.
What's the purpose
of Skin So Soft?
You don't need a PhD
to figure this out.
Skin So Soft is about beauty,
and hope, and lusciousness,
and all that good,
aesthetic stuff.
And then you find out that
moms are buying Skin So
Soft as an insect repellent.
OMG.
This was not your intent.
Your positioning was not "better
for your children than DDT."
That was not the plan.
But I'll tell you something.
You know what?
If moms want to buy Skin So
Soft for their children's insect
repellent--
hallelujah.
Declare victory.
If people want to use Canva for
things that we never intended--
hallelujah.
Declare victory.
For those of you not
from Silicon Valley,
let me explain something to you.
The way it works
in Silicon Valley
is we throw a lot of
things against the wall.
A very few number stick.
Then we go up to
the wall, and we
paint the bullseye around
it, and we declare victory.
We hit the bullseye.
You can always hit the bullseye
if you paint the bullseye
after you see what sticks, OK?
Let 100 flowers blossom.
Don't be proud.
You think you have a
spreadsheet, database,
and word processing machine?
Come to find you have a
desktop publishing machine?
Hallelujah.
Declare victory.
We intended Macintosh to be
a desktop publishing machine.
Let 100 flowers blossom.
Number eight.
Number eight is
the hardest lesson
to learn for any evangelist,
which is churn, baby, churn.
It means that you take
version 1 of your product
and make it 1.1, 1.2,
1.3, 1.4, 1.5, 2.0.
Oh my god.
I used to think that a
revolution at innovation
was an event.
It's not an event.
It is a process.
It's one of the hardest
things to learn.
Because you think you ship, and
then your biggest problem will
be, can you scale fast enough?
A few times in my
career, I would like
to have that as my problem.
Can we scale fast enough?
Scaling fast enough is
not usually the problem.
The problem is usually,
can we get the dogs
to eat the food at all?
Churn, baby, churn.
It's great discipline.
Number nine.
Number nine is that it is very
important to build an ecosystem
if you truly want
to achieve success,
because an ecosystem will do
things that you don't want
to do, you cannot do, maybe
you shouldn't even do.
Imagine Android without you.
Imagine iOS without
the iOS developers.
Imagine all the
software companies
without their dealers, and their
VARs, and their consultants,
and all that kind of stuff.
If you're a restaurant,
is it just the food?
Or is it also the
relationship with the waiters
and the waitresses,
with the valet company,
with the organic farms, with
the totality of the community?
Build an ecosystem.
An ecosystem will rescue you.
An ecosystem will do
things that you cannot do,
you should not do,
you don't want to do.
Part of the technical
ramifications
of building an ecosystem
is you always have APIs
and you have documentation.
When Apple announced
the iPhone in 2007,
the first version of the iPhone
was a closed architecture.
You could only add
functionality to the iPhone
by creating Safari plugins.
A year later, Apple
completely reversed itself
and made it possible
to make native apps,
and the rest is history.
If we had stuck
with a closed system
and not had a iOS ecosystem, I
think iPhone would have failed.
The key is to
build an ecosystem.
You are part of the
Android ecosystem.
Also, build an ecosystem
for your product.
Number 10.
Number 10 is you have to
learn to ignore naysayers.
Evangelists selling
dreams are always
going to encounter naysayers.
There are two kinds of
naysayers in the world.
I call them bozos, OK?
There are two kinds
of bozos in the world.
One kind of bozo is
slovenly, disgusting,
pocket-protector, Japanese
watch, rusty car, a loser.
You look at that person,
you say, you are a loser.
That bozo is not dangerous
because only losers
listen to losers.
The dangerous bozo
is the winner bozo.
The winner bozo dresses
in all-black, which
I'm free to say that today.
The winner bozo is
rich and famous.
The winner bozo is well-known.
And many people think that
rich and famous equals smart.
Rich and famous, 50% of the
time, equals lucky, not smart.
If rich and famous always
parsed to smart, arguably,
we would listen to Kanye West
about constitutional law, Tom
Cruise about spirituality,
Kim Kardashian about how
to travel in France safely.
You cannot make this assumption
that rich and famous equals
smart.
So I need to inoculate you
because I think that bozosity
is just like the flu.
How do you fight
bozosity and naysaying?
You get a little bit
of it in your life
so that when you encounter it in
your career as an entrepreneur,
as an employee,
when you encounter
big flu, big bozosity, big
saying, big negativity,
big stupidity, you've
built up the resistance.
So I have one
example here for you.
"There is no reason
why anyone would
want a computer in their home."
Ken Olsen, founder of DEC.
Many of you are
too young to know,
but DEC was an extremely
successful minicomputer
company.
And so Ken Olsen was an
extremely successful innovator,
revolutionary.
He changed the
face of computing.
We went from mainframe to mini
because of Ken Olsen and DEC.
So imagine you're Steve
and Woz, Larry and Sergey,
and someone says
to you, you know,
you need some adult supervision.
You need someone who's
been there and done
that, someone who's built a
hardware company, had to scale,
had to encounter all
these challenges.
Someone like Ken
Olsen, Steve and Woz.
Go talk to Ken Olsen.
Get him to invest.
Get him to be a director.
Get him to be an advisor.
So let's just say you get
in an elevator one day,
and there he is,
Ken freaking Olsen.
And you say to Mr. Olsen,
you know, Mr. Olsen,
we have a different
vision for computing.
We think that computers
should be small, and cheap,
and easy to use.
Small, and cheap, and easy.
So small, so cheap,
so easy to use,
Mr. Olsen, that you could have
a computer in your house, Mr.
Olsen.
And Mr. Olsen says, son,
let me tell you something--
"There is no reason
why anyone would want
a computer in their house."
Let's say they wanted to
balance their checkbook.
They will get in their car,
drive back to the office,
and use Quicken, running
on a DEC minicomputer.
What's the problem?
So before you ruin your
life, learn COBOL or FORTRAN,
and come work for DEC.
And there would
be no Apple today.
So I'm trying to tell you that
overcoming bozosity, overcoming
negativity, is a big
challenge, because it often
comes from people that you
think you should respect,
and they know what
they're doing.
I'm not saying that everybody
who tells you you'll fail
is wrong.
Frankly, most of the
time, they'll be right.
But if you always listen to
those people and never try,
you will never know.
And that is the
worst outcome of all.
"There's no reason
why anyone would
want a computer in their home."
And this is my last slide.
This is my last slide
because I think that this
should be your mantra.
This is how you should
approach your life
if you're an entrepreneur,
an innovator,
in the tech business.
Most of the time, when you see
this, it's the opposite way.
Some things need to be
seen to be believed.
If you show me a Macintosh,
if you show me an Android,
if you show me iOS, if you
show me Canva, if you show me
Privy, when you have millions
of users of all these products,
that's when I'll believe it.
That's not how the world
works in innovation.
The world works like this.
If you believe in
Macintosh, if you
will create products
for Macintosh,
if you believe in
Android, and you'll
create products for Android,
if you believe in Canva
and start creating graphics,
if you believe in Privy
and start creating
a social network,
because of the ecosystem,
because of the installed base,
because of the use of it,
then it'll become true,
and you will truly,
truly see it.
Some things need to be
believed to be seen.
So the art of evangelism
is all about getting
into that upper
right-hand corner, right?
You want something
unique and valuable.
You're going to need to suck up.
Come to grips with that.
You're going to need to
reduce all the friction.
Make it so easy to sign up.
Imagine if you're an
evangelist for the environment.
You have the Sierra Club.
You're in charge of
Sierra Club membership.
And you said to
people, well, if you
want to be an evangelist
for the environment,
you have to donate
$10,000, or you
have to chain yourself
to a tree as loggers
are about to cut it down.
You probably won't
get a lot of members.
You say to someone
who wants to become
an evangelist for
the environment,
take a shorter shower.
Recycle your cans, and
bottles, and newspapers.
You want to give them
a slippery slope.
Suck them into your cause.
Just remember, OK?
When all things
are said and done,
it is all about
spreading the good news.
Good news that you make
people more creative,
more productive, that
you're denting the universe,
that you're changing the world.
I like to call this
Guy's Golden Touch.
So Guy's Golden Touch is not
whatever I touch turns to gold.
Oh, god, I wish that were true.
I wish that were true.
Guy's Golden Touch is
whatever is gold, Guy touches.
So find something great.
Find something great.
Reduce the friction.
Learn to suck up.
Get it into that upper
right-hand corner.
Build an ecosystem around it.
Don't take negativity.
And change the world.
And that's the
art of evangelism.
Thank you very much.